estás graficando el rectángulo abc de en
el plano coordenada los siguientes son
tres de los vértices del rectángulo
cuáles son las coordenadas del punto de
una buena manera de para atacar este
problema es bueno vamos a replicar estos
puntos parece que todos están en el
primer cuadrante entonces nos vamos a
enfocar en el primer cuadrante dibujo
los ejes entonces aquí está el eje de
las yes y acá tenemos al eje de las x
ahora veamos el valor más alto que tengo
para el eje de las x es bueno yo tengo x
igual a 2 x igual a 5 x 5 parece que x
llega hasta 5 entonces pongo 1 2 3 4 5
ahí están los 5 de hecho los voy a
enumerar 1 2 3 4 5 ahora el valor de ye
más alto tenemos un 1 otro 1 y un 6
entonces
2 3 4 5 6 lo sé número 1 2 3 4 5 y 6
ahora vamos a replicar estos puntos
primero vamos con el punto a el punto a
está ubicado en 2,1 entonces x igualados
y igual a 1 a este punto ahora vamos con
el punto b que está en 5,1 entonces x
igual a 5 que igual a 1 b está justo
aquí y ahora vamos con el punto c el
punto se está en x 5 y 6
entonces x igual a 5 y 6 lo que se nos
pregunta es que averigüemos dónde está
el punto de observa que este es un
rectángulo y por ser rectángulos sus
lados opuestos son paralelos entonces
tenemos tenemos ángulos rectos en todos
los vértices tenemos lados opuestos
paralelos por lo tanto el punto d tendrá
la misma coordenada en x
que este punto lo escribo de tendrá una
coordenada en x2
y tendrá la misma coordenada y nye que
este punto así que tendrá una coordenada
en ye de 6 por lo tanto que está en el
punto 26 y puedes ver que cuando hacemos
eso nos queda un lindo rectángulo cierto
vamos a dibujarlo entonces aquí está a
un lado del rectángulo acá está otro
lado del rectángulo otro lado y otro
lado y ahí lo tienes el rectángulo pero
lo que es más importante respondimos la
pregunta cuáles son las coordenadas del
punto de 2,6